[Music]
so time for the press preview then a
first look at what is on friday's front
pages it's time to see what's making the
headlines for the columnist and
broadcaster steve richards and former
government special adviser salma shah
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight evening to you both
let's start with a look at those front
pages then according to the telegraph
discussions are underway between
ministers to allow people to cut the
weight for a cove booster vaccination
from six months after their second jab
to just five
the daily mail says nine million people
could get a third dose of a coronavirus
vaccine earlier than originally planned
in response to the new vaccines minister
maggie throughp having made no national
media appearances since her appointment
the eye declares her missing
meanwhile the guardian reports that gps
in england have threatened industrial
action as the row over face-to-face
appointments deepens
let's slide in your metro a court has
heard that the man accused of murdering
sir david amis had plotted for two years
to try to kill an mp that's on their
front page
also the lead story in tomorrow's times
and the ft carries a prediction from the
bank of england's new chief economist
that inflation is likely to reach close
to or even slightly above five percent
next year
and i'm joined tonight by steve richards
and sal michael good to see you both um
so salmer let's kick off shall we with
the front of the daily mail it's also
covered in the daily telegraph their
front page as well
nine million people set to get booster
jab early because at the moment you have
to wait six months after your second jab
but what the prime minister is hoping
that that might be brought forward to
just five months
yes and i think a part of this is
because uh the whole of government is
now very worried about what's going to
happen to the nhs in a winter crisis so
not only do you have the lingering
effects of covid and um you know the
fact that efficacy is waning after two
jabs as we've as we've heard from from
lots of people
um that you've got the new threat of flu
and the fact that people are not as
immune
and won't um sort of where they will
wear these illnesses as easily as they
may have done if we were all still
moving about
and the fact that you still have a
backlog so you have this absolute triple
threat um
for the nhs
and what this suggests is the government
is very very serious about trying to
minimize that risk
minimize the pressure on the nhs and so
are desperately trying to make sure that
those boosters are getting into arms
which um i think has been a bit
difficult for them when you think about
um the take up this time round for the
booster yes steve the government's
strategy very much uh we'll keep things
as we are we're just going to really try
and accelerate that booster program and
it's interesting on the front of the
telegraph they go into a bit of detail
here
if the booster jab weight could be cut
it would mean most over 65s could be
vaccinated by early november rather than
early december and all over 70s in the
coming days and weeks rather than by
mid-november and it could actually have
quite a big impact couldn't it
yeah i mean the the worry is that this
is
the sole kind of instrument uh to deal
with the rising
infections uh the vaccination uh we have
the laxis range of constraints i think i
read the other day in the western world
um here in the uk
um so
obviously the focus on the vaccine is
huge
and unsurprisingly therefore i mean it
you know a wider range of measures might
mean the total dependence on the vaccine
was not quite so great but as it is um
yeah it makes absolute sense and will
make a difference and
the more and speedily people can get it
the better
but it is a curious thing about this
prime minister he is famously
flexible on so many issues you know one
minute of keynesian the next thatcherite
and so on but on this his libertarian
instincts prevail every time and we're
in this familiar pattern of people
working within the nhs warning that um
it's reaching another sort of crisis but
but of course steve it's not clear cut
is it you know we're in a situation
where wales has the highest number of
cases but also the strictest measures
you know they've been wearing masks for
ages and also scotland has the lowest
number of cases but also has mass
indoors and vaccination passports it's
not it's not an easy one to
to work out is it just very briefly
steve
no but uh no one's been asked to be sort
of hopelessly constrained we're not
talking about a lot down here we're
talking about relatively
manageable measures that might i'm you
know i don't but it might make a
difference as well as this dependency
which is great on the vaccine yeah let's
bring in the front of the times uh
salmon some good news uh for once
booster dose of fisa vaccine offers near
total protection so if you do get that
third jab uh certainly if it's pfizer
then you you're doing really well
yeah i mean this is really quite
incredible and it's again another
testament to
um the amazing pharmaceutical companies
i mean who knew anybody would be saying
that about pharmaceutical companies um
but their work and their research and
and what is being produced so i think
you know
off to pfizer but what i do think is
interesting about this is that there is
an element of this story that suggests
that actually the government is trying
to entice people into getting those
boosters so i go back to the point that
i made earlier um is that there are not
enough shots in arms and i think this is
going to be the critical problem uh the
critical structural problem that the
government is facing so having that bit
of good news i think might sort of
encourage people who maybe don't have
you know the text message system from
the gp or whatever it might be
and with the infrastructure of the
vaccination program having been wound
down
might encourage them then to go and seek
that
vaccination
yeah and you mentioned gps there so
we're going to um uh skip on to the
front of the guardian uh steve because
gps are threatening industrial action uh
in a row with uh uh minister is their
headline this is all about um
face-to-face appointments but of course
it's the worst possible time isn't it
for gps to be threatening strike action
when we're trying to get those jabs into
arms
it would be a nightmare to have them on
strike now and it's a really interesting
conundrum and it poses a fundamental
question how much power should patients
have um because basically from my
understanding the dispute is over
whether the patients have the right to
insist on a face-to-face
appointment or whether
the gps have the right to decide whether
to meet people face to face and um this
whole issue of how you empower patients
the degree to which they should be
empowered the degree to which often
under-resourced or overstretched gps
must make judgments is at the heart of
this particular conundrum
and
the threat to strike is a is a sort of
potent weapon in itself but let's hope
this issue can be resolved without it
yeah someone just a very brief word on
this uh from you if you could
it feels like there's been a bit of a
misunderstanding in terms of
communication because the government
said that they want to give money to gps
to make access a lot easier so i hope it
is resolved and swiftly because i don't
see there are going to be any winners if
there's if their strike action
okay uh thank you both for the moment
stay where you are because coming up
donald trump's new social media platform
claims it will offer truth but will it
we'll discover that next
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview steve and salmer still with me
um steve that front page of the
financial times uh they've got the first
interview with hugh pill in his new role
he's a bank of england economist and
he's rather gloomy saying that uh
inflation heading to five percent or
potentially more
there's a lot to be gloomy about but
whether uh and the consequence of this
the ft uh says in its splash or
reporting him
is a possible interest rate rise and
this is not a scientific
exercise i mean it's been removed from
government of course until 1997
governments took that decision now it's
being made by the bank of england but
i've heard former members of the
monetary policy committee saying this
would be absolutely the wrong time to do
it um with all the other
pressures on consumers to hit uh
borrowers with a big well who knows what
the size of it would be but with an
interest rate rise so i think it's a
it's a difficult decision
that part of their remit is to act in
ways that uh bring inflation down when
it goes above certain levels
but
this economy is so fragile at the moment
with so many things going on price rises
in all kinds of sectors um it's not by
any means a straightforward decision but
a number of interviews emerging from the
bank of england suggests they're
inclined to take it
yes almost certainly uh unprecedented
times and uh it's understandable why why
people are jittery
yeah of course because it means some
serious um
as steve rightly pointed out some
serious consequences uh from the bank of
england in terms of what happens to
those people who probably already feel
that they're struggling um at the moment
whether it be with um cost of living in
terms of day-to-day or
mortgages or whatever um
you know the interest rates will affect
which is essentially everything but what
i what i think is interesting is that we
have gotten so used to
uh what effectively people have called
cheap money for such a long time that
they that the impact of this will be
incredibly significant on on the economy
so the bank of england is going to have
to be incredibly cautious about how it
stages itself
out of this current low interest period
and i also think that the treasury
probably needs to start accepting that
they have to move away from this line
that they've continued with which is um
inflation rises and inflation risk rise
is temporary because it doesn't look
like it is
okay and let's finish uh with a story
about donald trump steve it's in the
metro donald trump says we live in a
world where the taliban has a huge
presence on twitter yet your favorite
american president has been silenced
this is unacceptable so he's setting up
his own social media app
well i think us two were on the uh night
it emerged that
twitter had banned
the then uh incumbent of the white house
from uh tweeting any longer and i'm no
fan of him or his tweets um but i
thought it was wrong but an elective
figure should be silenced by non-elected
people so well he's not elected now
although he kind of thinks he still is
uh because he thinks he was robbed of it
in uh his kind of fantasy world um but
if he wants to uh
tweet on some alternative platform
let him um you know he was an elected
figure
and um the way to
challenge him is not to silence him but
to
expose his
tweets for what they are yeah salma will
he be reading his messages
i won't but i do think it's marvelous
that it's called truth because obviously
the concept is so subjective as donald
trump himself has proven
no fake news there only the truth all
right steve and salman thank you very
much in the